let's get into the cma awards so a lot
of anticipation for this year's awards
was around the entertainer of the year
category so garth brooks yeah
got a lot of backlash last year after he
beat carrie underwood
for the award in july garth decided to
remove his name from contention for this
year
uh yeah now when the nominees were
announced both carrie
and miranda lambert were nominated two
solo females being nominated in that
category
has not happened in more than 40 years
so there was a lot of hope that one of
them would actually take it
and vulture even wrote an article about
why
it was time for miranda to win who has
never won that award right well eric
church who has also never previously won
took the price home so here's that
moment but first here's miranda
performing settling down
and speaking to abc before the show
[Music]
with my head up in the clouds
[Music]
entertainer of the year i just got
chills for you as a woman
standing alongside your fellow nominee
carrie underwood yes
i mean this is history-making the fact
that you are with you have three amazing
men also in the category don't want to
take anything away from them but yes
yes i think it's the first time two
women have been in the category together
since 1979. yes so it's about time but
i'm through i mean it's a tough
competition
i mean also this year to me the award is
more about
how you represent yourself in country
music as a whole
you know without touring this year we're
basing it on the little tours we got to
do
but i think it's just about how you've
how you've given to the business and to
the
to the fans over time you know so
everybody deserves it
and the cma award for entertainer of the
year goes to
eric church
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there was ever a year not to win this
award
okay so jg says sorry not the best
choice as even my hubby said who is eric
church
well so brilliant i think roz and i are
gonna have a different perspective than
you are because you're in the country
music world so you start what are your
thoughts on
these awards and yeah you know i
i think uh you know
everyone who was nominated
was a winner yeah and it sounds like a
cop-out type of answer where it's like
everybody wins
but honestly to be able to be
nominated means that it came down to a
small group of people
then making a decision on who it is and
those decisions are not
science those decisions are perspectives
and so we have to remember that even
though a group of people may have
a perspective on who won if you were
nominated or even if you weren't
nominated at
all if what you do is meaningful and
significant and impactful to the people
that you're trying to reach
then you are you know everyone is
entertainer of the year to someone right
and that i think is is is a better way
to look at it because not
only one person is going to win any of
these
categories and congratulations to all of
the people who do win i would like to at
some point win one of those awards but
i think if we put more emphasis on the
awards than we do
the work and what the work has the
potential to do
then i think we're playing the wrong
game
and so it's nice to get awarded for
things but i think
what miranda and what kerry and what
eric and everyone who was nominated for
that category and all of the other
categories do
is so much more important and so much
more significant than whether or not
they came away at the end of a year with
a trophy
because i think the you know the
satisfaction comes from the fact that
millions of people are inspired
by their work and millions of people are
encouraged and uplifted by what they do
yeah i think that there's a reason that
i don't have a vote
in entertainer of the year because i
don't know enough about
any of these artists to actually sort of
have have a say but i
i find that these headlines are
interesting man and he said at the
beginning where this is you know this is
not the right year to win because
with garth brooks bowing out and now you
have this
you know are are the headlines that you
know eric
church actually won because he's
deserving or are the headlines
eric church beat miranda lambert let's
discuss and
and i think that those are sort of two
different things and and one of them
is a good place for eric church and one
of them is a really not cool
very uncomfortable place to be today and
i i think that that's kind of you know
where where the where the conversation
is
and these are conversations that need to
happen but i just in situations like
this
i can't help but feel bad for both i
can't help but feel bad for miranda
and then i can't help but feel bad for
eric for winning because it's never
about that his
whether he's deserving or not it's only
about the fact that he miranda
and and that becomes the conversation so
i just i really feel for everybody in
these situations
congratulations eric yeah she's
so well deserved you're awesome so happy
that you're nominated why bs is
brilliant you have the right attitude
a schultz has never heard of him either
i think i think that uh
you know as it as it pertains to uh
who deserve to win or anything like that
i can't i can't make that determination
i think that
that miranda is an incredible
entertainer
and was very deserving of
that award but i also think that eric is
deserving of that award i think there
are a lot of people who are deserving of
that award which is why
it kind of changes every year you know
and
and why there were people who were
nominated because they were all those
people were all in contention and all
deemed to be at the at the top of of the
pack so i think everyone as i said
everyone's a winner
yeah what was what i was saying the
different perspective of me and rosa
have
and we've talked about this before that
miranda and kerry
really exist in that pop culture world
like me and roz don't really know the
country music world that well so when
miranda and kerry release music in that
we hear about it i don't really hear
when luke bryan when jason aldean
when luke combs releases music those
guys are absolutely huge but they
haven't crossed over
into that pop culture world so that's
why i mean rods are always surprised
that
cam miranda don't win these awards and
came miranda had never won entertainer
of the year
like that blows our mind because that
this is who we hear about yeah
i just think a little a little bit at
this point i know karen miranda have won
a lot of awards but they don't win the
big ones
we know what's got going on with
grammy's last couple years that jay-z
and beyonce have decided to say okay
fine
if you're going to just use us to you
know nominate us and get us to perform
in the show to get ratings but you're
not going to give us the big awards
it might be at this point that miranda
and kerry have a conversation with each
other
and say you know do we keep going i
don't think it's that extreme but i
think you you have to start thinking
that way that
miranda and carrie underwood have never
won entertainer of the year
we're still nominated we still perform
on these things at a certain point
when are we when is this more beneficial
for them than it is for us so i think
it's a conversation that they might need
to have at some point
yeah and to be honest if if they made
that decision
uh that they didn't want to do it i
would understand where they were coming
from
and i also think you know
race and gender are not the same thing
but a lot of the barriers that exist
in country music and in the music
industry
as it pertains to people of color and
women
are sometimes kind of similar and so
you know in the same way that you don't
see a ton of women
winning that award or even nominated for
that award you also don't really see a
ton of
people of color men or women getting
getting nominated for those awards and
winning those awards
so you know there's there's a lot of
room to grow
i think and i think the fact that people
are having the conversation
is a step in the right direction even if
the end result of winning the award
or the person that you want winning the
award isn't yet happening i think the
fact that people
are bowing out uh you know those types
of gestures mean something
and i think in time we will see
you know if the work that people are
putting in will catch up
with what actually ends up happening
yeah for sure
did great maybe you can help me with
this before we continue did garth brooks
remove himself
just from this year or for all future
entertainers though i don't know so like
he said because
so can he be back in the mix next year
all over again maybe yeah
maybe yeah it would be a little i mean i
don't think anyone is trying to take
themselves out of contention forever
because what if like my whole thing is
this like what if you actually
are deserving of the award
i don't think you should always take
yourself out you know
i don't think you should always have to
take yourself out if you decide to do
that
as like a you know a form of
protest or something like you know go
for it
but i don't think he should be dis you
know that he should feel like he needs
to disqualify himself
in perpetuity no like garth is an
incredible entertainer